you're probably wondering are we in a
recession right now I mean maybe we
don't know yet we're getting
contradictory signals from the economy
here in the United States we had two
quarters in a row which is like six
months of a shrinking GDP this for a lot
of analysts is the definition of a
recession but then the news came out
that the third quarter of 2022 the
economy grew again I mean it was by less
than one percent but it grew so that's
not a recession yet plus during a
recession the number of unemployed
people spikes but check out where the
unemployment rate is right now it's nice
and low that's not recession what we do
know is that people are a little bit
freaked out to be more cautious about
their spending and that's because of a
cocktail of causes that you've heard
about in the news covid-19 giving way to
Energy prices and supply chain
disruptions and this war in Ukraine
people are making hundreds of millions
of little micro decisions every day to
spend less money in an economy that only
works if everyone spends more money and
pushes businesses to make more stuff